[Music]
parents across the country know
firsthand how the pandemic has been
affecting their children's mental health
now first on cbs morning's a new poll
from the child advocacy advocacy group
are on our sleeves shows how those
challenges are affecting parents in the
workplace the survey found that 53
percent have missed work at least once a
month to deal with their children's
mental health and 54 percent have
interrupted their work day at least one
once a month to address a child's mental
health needs marty bletzel post is
executive director of on our sleeves
good morning how are you doing good
morning thanks for having me so what did
the survey reveal about the impact of
children's mental health on parents
well even when parents are at work 30 to
50 percent of their mind share can be on
worrying about whether their child's
mental health is developing as it should
and whether everything's okay so yes
parents are missing work and
interrupting work and even when they're
at work this is on their mind all the
time so 41 of parents surveyed said that
their focus and their concern on their
children's mental health increased
during the pandemic yes um why is that
so and do you believe that once the the
covet rates decline and restrictions
lift that these things will be resolved
it's hard for us to predict the future
but our behavioral health experts are
looking at the past 10-year trends and
seeing that children's mental health
issues are rising and parents are more
and more concerned so if we look back to
look forward we have to be ready for new
adjustments as life after the pandemic
continues to change and we have to be
ready to adjust with it and adjust for
our kids and help them have
conversations about their mental health
with everything that's coming at them so
what about parents that work from home
like how has that impacted their
children's mental health and then also
theirs well we asked parents how
disruptive has your child's mental
health been and how disruptive has
remote schooling been and they were only
four percentage points apart so we know
that it's been very difficult in both of
those scenarios to stay focused and get
work done when all this other
concern is coming at them and i can
assume that there's a correlation but
working from home and then also
doing two things at once being a teacher
as well that has to be difficult on
parents right right parents are used to
multitasking but the last couple years
have been extra extra multitasking
effort now what do parents have
available
for
ways to help them deal with their
children's mental health situation the
first thing we can all do is start to
break down the stigma around this topic
half of all lifetime mental illness will
present before the age of 14.
so children have mental health needs
just like adults so if we can start to
have this conversation with each other
with coaches with counselors with
teachers and in the workplace then
employers can join us in finding
solutions and helping their employees be
more focused and productive when they're
on the job we've been talking about
removing the stigma
surrounding
mental health for a long time and like
you said it is difficult in the
workplace so what kind of advice do you
give to parents that have to deal with
that because sometimes you you don't
want to say anything right to your
friends to your family members and
really to your co-workers right we asked
parents about that and coworkers and hr
and colleagues they came in at the
bottom of the list of adults that
parents want to talk to
but 85 percent of parents said they want
to talk to another adult they feel like
that would be helpful and we know that
workplaces can connect them to resources
so we suggest that you start small find
one other parent in the workplace that
you can trust
ask hr some really general questions
about what benefits you have available
what resources are there without
mentioning a specific concern or
diagnosis so that you can get a sense of
what you can do and then start to think
about how do you build effort inside the
workplace and be more transparent and
say things like i need to take a mental
health day with my kid or i need to be
present with my child through something
that's really you know impacting him or
her and start to have these phrases come
out so that we can all just break that
stigma um communicating that helps marty
bledsoe post thank you so much i
appreciate you joining us if you feel
like your child is in danger of hurting
themselves contact the national suicide
prevention lifeline at
800
800-273-8255